in rhede was glaube ich willkommen beim
neuen video auf jeden fall der rat am
zocken ich habe mir eine playstation
fähige kaufkraft 40.000 euro auf gesandt
wo ich jetzt an gemacht wollte ich gar
nicht haben so lange bis die ausgeht
nein wir wollen dich nicht anmachen ich
habe immer versucht jetzt ganz lange
darauf zu drücken weil normalerweise
geht dann jeder computer aus aber bei
playstation ist nicht so auf jeden fall
gespielt und das war so ein spiel da
kann man halt so immer so die gegner
auch in seinem raum hören also wenn man
mit denen in einem team ist dann hört
man die wenn die halt die mit sich
selber lachen miteinander man keine
ahnung auf jeden fall waren also zwei
typen und der eine hat mit dem anderen
zusammen gezogen und ja mal die ganze
zeit gelacht wirklich ganzen die sind
noch mega auf den sack gegangen
aber okay ich hab mir so nicht allein
ich das voll normaal und der eine part
und irgendwann länger weg dann kam aber
wieder und hat gesagt hey ticker sorry
meine frühere hand gezogen ich darf mir
dann so direkt ein cooler ist eine coole
freunde bisher immer cool dass du wieder
zocken lässt ducati geht ja eigentlich
runter dann immer so wenn deine freundin
im zocken besser ist als du dann ist
schon scheiße irgendwie ne ich habe es
auf jeden fall eigentlich so voll
gefeiert und dann kamen diese andere
typen so irgendwas von wegen öl debatte
lässt seine freundin spielen mädchen
dürfen doch nicht zocken oder irgendwie
so was hat er gesagt ich weiß nicht mehr
genau auf jeden fall rat so betont dass
er halt meintest du deine freundin
spielen bist du blöd mädchen gehören
nicht vor der konsole so darf ich mir so
das war wirklich erst eben und dann habe
ich mir gesagt moment mal es gibt
wirklich viele jungs dieser auffassung
sind macht doch einfach mal ein video
dazu ich hatte jedoch kein video thema
deswegen jetzt soll also ein bisschen
darum ich wollte euch darüber lachen
oder weinen und könnt ihr auch gerne in
die kommentare schreiben aber glaube
jetzt erstmal weiter also ich persönlich
hab eigentlich so wirklich überhaupt
keinen plan wie es jetzt dazugekommen
ist das mädchen halt so nach der meinung
irgendwelcher jungs weil das bekomme ich
wirklich oft mit dass jung zu sagen
mädchen zocken scheiße versteht ihr ich
weiß wirklich überhaupt nicht wie man
darauf
irgendwie kommt ja aber irgendwann muss
ja geben dass manche so denken
wenn ich einfach so kommt deswegen
artikulation bisher gedanken gemacht und
bin so auch folgendes gekommen ja also
ich erkläre mir das jetzt ganz einfach
so dass spezielle zum beispiel bei
ballerspielen irgendwelche jungs nicht
so denken das ist ein ballerspiel dass
die ski zu männlich das dürfen mädchen
nicht spielt so versteht ihr beim
fußball ballett american football club
das macht auch jungs ihr wisst was ich
meine so fußball und ballett ist ein
gutes beispiel aber dann müsste man ja
eigentlich schon differenzieren weil ich
meine es gibt ja wirklich speziell
spiele diese nur für mädchen bestimmt ja
weil ich meinen welcher junge spielt
irgendwie so ein spiel wo man seine
katze streicheln muss oder seinen hund
füttern muss oder mit seinem hund auf
klo gehen muss so was gibt es auch
nennen aber das spiel doch eigentlich
glaube ich so mädchen so höchstens bis
zwölf jahren versteigert dann mit 13
jahren auf seine katze über die play
station machte das noch wenn du jetzt 13
bis 14 9 auf 15 16 17 oder 18 ist rein
gehst du noch deine katze über irgend so
ein nintendo ds spiel oder was weiß ich
schreib zwar in die kommentare
auf jeden fall verstehe ich diesen
gedankengang wirklich überhaupt nicht
also 0,0 jetzt hab ich mein handy ich
meinen computer eines playstation games
xbox gamer für games sie sind ja so
wirklich dazu bestimmt außer so lernen
spieler hat also sind dazu bestimmt dass
man spaß hat und wieso sollte man diesen
spaß dann mädchen in der hinsicht nicht
heißt es wenn sie von zwei deutschen
also versteht ihr verstehe ich überhaupt
nicht ich meine auf der verpackung von
diesem spiel hier
juni in black ops treibt da steht ja
auch ich drauf nur für jungs bestimmt
oder wenn du ein mädchen bis dann leg es
wieder zurück oder verschenken an alex
könnte übrigens machen wenn ihr spiel
habt ihr nicht wollt dann schenken
ich will dir also sollte man den mädchen
dann den spaß nun ich könnte weil sie
weiblich sind oder was keinen sinn ohne
scheiß keinen sinn außerdem ich verstehe
das auch gar nicht wie dieser typ das
sagen kann ich mein ich zum beispiel
okay ich will jetzt nicht wieder alles
verallgemeinern aber ich finde das ist
falls paris und das macht auch um mega
spaß zumal mit mädchen zusammen zocken
kann oder nicht und wenn man dann so
schlecht ist wie ich dann gewinnt man
vielleicht auch mal das war jetzt wieder
ein
nein das sollte weil es ist ja so also
okay ich sag nichts mehr also an den typ
der das gesagt hat passt mal auf stell
dir vor du hast eine freundin und die
mag es überhaupt nicht zu zocken dann
ist es doch immer scheiße wenn du in
ihrer gegenwart zurück stell dir vor die
marke zu zocken und du findest das auch
okay dann könnt ihr mal zusammen zocken
du gehst ihr da nicht auch an sagt sie
gibt denen ich hoffe sagt das ist doch
richtig cool ich mein was fast nur
dagegen also zog so viel können und
vielleicht könnt ihr mir dann auch mal
konkurrenz machen
das war jetzt nicht so gemeint also doch
das habe ich so gemeint das habe ich
komplett so gemeint ja heute
folgerichtig video gefallen hat dass auf
jeden fall mal dort nach oben da mal
gucken ob sieben oder acht und neun
weiß ich nicht also könnt gerne der
bewertung da lassen ansonsten im schrank
eure kommentare in die kommentare also
eure meinung als kommentar und in die
kommentare würd mich interessieren wie
steht ihr zu dem ganzen thema findet ihr
das cool wenn mädchen zocken oder nicht
oder wie top gear selber keine ahnung
schreibt irgendwas in die kommentare was
euch dazu gerade einfällt wird mich
freilich ist wieder kräftig durch und
dann sehen wir uns am nächsten mittwoch
wieder ich meinen traum auf den sonntag